teror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a m stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV hello I'm Douglas Murray and this is
uncensored tonight in a New Year message
the Israeli military warns the conflict
in Gaza will continue throughout 2024
can the war continue to be justified
after so much suffering and bloodshed or
is it necessary to destroy Hamas for the
safety of the region and the world a
satirical take on political correctness
and over sensitivity or just plain
offensive we'll debate whether the
backlash to Ricky ja and Dave
Chappelle's new Netflix shows are
Justified and should King Charles agree
to vacate the throne in a few years time
to let Prince William take over I'll
talk to the guardian journalist who says
the abdication of the queen of Denmark
puts our archaic system to
[Music]
shame live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening and welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored I'm Douglas
Murray filling in for Pierce for the
rest of the week what better way to
ensure the happiest of starts to a new
year I hear you all cry only joking
peers I know you're watching by the way
and don't forget the sunscreen over the
next 3 days my guests and I will be
looking at the big topics and themes
that will dominate the global agenda in
2020 24 we'll be covering everything
from the potentially gamechanging
elections in the US and the UK to the
seemingly NeverEnding Madness of the
culture wars we might even touch on the
odd Royal story I of course am the
biggest Harry and Megan fan so expect
some marle Mania to break out this week
indeed this is going to be a mar arama
that's just another joke Pier sorry if
you're still watching and trust me folks
he's still watching but we'll start with
the story I predict will continue to
dominate the headlines for the year
ahead War as regular viewers of unsensed
will know I spent the last few months of
2023 in Israel covering the conflict in
Gaza I saw firsthand the death and
Carnage Unleashed by hamaz on October
the 7th I visited the tunnels they used
to hide beneath the civilian population
and I experienced many times including
on this very show during a live
broadcast what it was like to be under
enemy fire
and I sorry there's an
incoming uh
incoming get safe
Douglas come
come and of course I got to see the
impact of Israel's massive response to
those massacres Hamas seized control of
the Gaza in 2006 to7 and they reduced it
to a terrorist State that's now in turn
being reduced to Rubble with the
displacement of hundreds of thousands of
people many Palestinian civilians
including children are caught in the
crossfire but I've never wavered in my
view that this war is not only just but
also necessary Israel has the right and
the need to defend itself and hamaz need
to be crushed for the sake of the region
and the world and that's why when it was
reported this afternoon that Hamas
Deputy head s alori has been killed in
an explosion south of Beirut I for for
one will shed no tears nobody could live
beside a terror group like Hamas we
couldn't hear in Britain and I don't see
why the Israelis should and yes I know
that isn't a consensus view there are
lots of people who vehemently disagree
with me so I'm Keen to explore not just
what has happened but what happens
next now joining me tonight to discuss
this is from Tel Aviv the former British
army officer and now Trustee of the UK
Friends of the the association for the
well-being of Israeli soldiers Colonel
Richard Kemp and from rala Palestinian
national initiative leader Mustafa bouti
thank you both for joining me let me
start with you if I may Mr bouti uh
we've just had this news in we've all
just heard it of the Deputy head of
Hamas being killed in Beirut obviously
this is the leader of the group that
killed Palestinians in the Ken Gaz in
2006 to 7 and of course one of the
people who planned the October the 7th
Massacre what's your response to his
killing
tonight well if you allow me and I hope
you will accept that from me I think
your presentation is absolutely
one-sided totally biased to the Israeli
side you speak about the right of Israel
to defend itself but you don't mention
the right of the Palestinian people to
defend themselves you fail to mention
that Israel is the aggressor which
started this terrible occupation since
56 years and Palestinian I as people
under occupation according to
international law have the right to
defend themselves and to resist
occupation you you failed to mention
that no less than 29,000 civilian
Palestinians have been killed by Israeli
bom mention that I mention that
including in no no you mentioned as if
they were killed on their own not by
Israeli bombardment what should be clear
here is that 29,000 Palestinians if we
include those under the rebel have been
killed by Israel terrible air strikes
and artillery bombardment including no
less than 12,000 children I've said so
many times on so many programs I'm
against the killing of any civilian
whether Palestinian or Israel but if you
speak about the killing of 30 Israeli
children you should also speak about the
12,000 Palestinian children who were
killed well
Mr do a followup May uh I did mention
the killing of children I did say that
that is appalling damage in the but let
me let me finish the question before you
try to answer a question I haven't yet
asked you said that the Palestinian
people are allowed to uh resist as you
call it what what does that look like in
your
view according to international law
people who are under occupation have the
right to resist in all forms including
military forms as long as they respect
international law and international
humanitarian law okay so what does it
look like do occupy Israel Israel wants
not only to look I've been struggling
with nonviolent resistance all my life I
was injured nine times by the Israeli
Army although I never used any weapon I
was shot I was shot twice but but you're
not telling me but you're not telling me
sirit a minute you're not telling me
what legitimate resistance
is legitimate resistance is all forms of
resistance that respect International
humanitarian law which means not
attacking civilians not attacking
children it's very clear that's what
international law says I am not creating
that okay but even when I was in my
white Court wait a minute when I was in
my white Court in treating an injured
person an Israeli sniper shot me twice
the same same mentality of these snipers
killed Shireen Abu your colleague the
journalist and nobody no Israeli was
indicted 303 of my Pro my colleagues
doctors nurses health professionals have
been killed by Israeli air strikes in
Gaza 104 ambulances were destroyed all
our our health centers were destroyed
this is not acceptable okay
thank Mr barti we have another guest so
I'd like to go over to Tel Aviv to
Colonel Richard Kemp what do you make of
what you've just
heard well I think um Mr barouti talks
about uh legitimate resistance adhering
to the laws of War uh well first of all
resistance to what the the Israelis
withdrew from Gaza in 2005 uh and and
set effect effectively set up a
two-state solution uh let let the
Palestinian Authority which was then
taken over by Hamas run their own
territory so what are they actually
resisting what's this resistance about
and when it comes to the laws of war the
people the Hamas butchers that Mr
barouti has been quoted as referring to
as our brave Fighters they went into
Israeli territory on the 7th of October
they raped burnt alive butchered cut off
their heads kidnapped
abused civilians and soldiers civilians
though which is you know against
obviously it's against any law of War it
was against the laws of war to kill
anyone inside another country but in in
that way but but to do to to to butcher
civilians like that what where's the
laws of war there and secondly ever
since that day and of course many many
times before his Brave Hamas Fighters as
he calls them have been firing Rockets
indiscriminate ly at civilian
populations inside Israel and they're
still doing so they won't be doing so
much longer because they're about to be
throttled by the IDF and not only that
but they've also been firing them from
within the civilian population that is
against the laws of armed conflict and
preventing the civilians from leaving
the combat areas when the IDF are trying
to warn them about attacks again against
the laws of arm conflict they've also
fired many of their Rockets into the
Gaza civilian population we just have to
look at the
Al Ali Hospital attack that was
attributed to the IDF but turned out to
be an Islamic Jihad another Brave
Islamic Jihad Fighters firing their own
Rockets into their own civilian
population let's not forget what Hamas
is all about here that the reason Hamas
launched this attack there are strategic
reasons of course but the the overriding
reason they launched this attack on the
7th of October and the reason they
launch all of their attacks is to force
Israel to defend itself from these
attacks which any country and every
country would do and has the right and
the obligation to do and in in carrying
out its reaction to these attacks Israel
unfortunately has no choice but to to
kill innocent civilians in the process
despite the efforts they take which are
enormous to avoid doing that but that's
what Hamas wants Hamas they don't they
don't just want civilians to protect
their terrorists they want Israel to
kill civilians so that Israel is then
condemned delegitimized vilified
isolated
around the world and it happen works
every time in the United Nations the
universities in in some governments
human rights groups always condemn
Israel that's what Hamas want and that
encourages Hamas to do it again and
again and again and by Mr barouti who
who claims to support peaceful
resistance by Mr barouti justifying what
they do he also has blood on his hands
from
encouraging I
abely going get a Mr vti you're going to
get a moment to respond to that I just
want to ask you first let's just clear
that this up before you do respond to
colon cemp did you call him as our brave
Fighters or
not I never said that no I don't know
you got that
from no it's not true you are putting
words in my mouth but let me let me
respond to what the colonal said the
colonial is said is reflecting clearly a
very clear white so Supremacy approach
it is okay Supremacy why don't you say
why don't you say why don't you say
clearly that you are supporting the
killing of Palestinian children why
don't you say clearly that you are
supporting the killing of Palestinian
civilians why don't you say that you are
supporting Israeli occupation of
Palestinian land and supporting three
terrible war crimes even the American
public is against that three war crimes
the war crime of genocide which the
international court of justice is
looking into now the war crime of
collective punishment and the war crime
of ethnic cleansing 90 wait a minute 90%
of the Palestinian people were eved from
their homes what would you have said if
Palestinians evicted Israelis from their
home well they Mr they have done why
don't you use the same standard I'm
going to go back I'm going to go back to
K moment but why why is why is this
white supremacy where did that come from
the Israeli public are not all white
because I don't I think you don't see us
white enough and you are against anybody
who's not white and that's why you
justify terrible atrocities that Israel
is committing and you are justifying not
only the fact that Israel is occupying
us but the fact that Israel conducted
the worst kind of ethnic cleansing in
1948 forcing 70% of the Palestinian
people out going to go back to are the
facts I'll just go back to colel km
quickly colel km you you said that he
that Mr VY said Brave Fighters were hamz
he says he didn't say that um who's
right well I certainly read him quote he
may not have said it but I read him
being quoted as saying I think it was
Middle East eye or something like that
but he can certainly if he'd like to
Google it to see what he actually said
he can find that on the internet and
what do you make of this claim and what
do you make of this claim Colonel Kemp
that everyone who justifies or in any
way on the side of Israel during this
war is a is a white supremacist because
Israel doesn't look like a very allwhite
country to me but I don't
know no I mean you know there's there
are all blends of um races in Israel and
one thing we should remember as well is
that there is a significant Muslim Arab
population in Israel and one thing that
I've observed in recent weeks is persed
a sky rocking a skyrocketing of support
for Israel among the Israeli Arab Muslim
population the the po po number polls
have shown that a huge grow growth of
support for Israel a greater association
with the state of Israel since the 7th
of October and that is partly due to the
fact that Hamas his his Brave fighters
from Hamas that that he clearly supports
came in and um and butchered not just uh
Israelis but Israeli Jews but they also
came and and killed a number of Arabs
and and and people from many different
ethnicities so what he's talking I think
it's a great throwaway line white
supremacy it obviously gets you know
it's one of these intersectional terms
you know me too and all this sort of
stuff it's it's he obviously thinks
that's going to Garner support for him
for people who uh you know do object
rightly object to the idea of white
supremacy but I don't think that comes
into this argument one little bit Mr
margi finally we've already got a few
seconds but you said we need to go back
to 1947 and
1948 what do you say to the people who
say you can go back thousands of years
and you never never have an end to this
argument well look Palestinians were
displaced from their country including
cities like Jaffa where my father lived
and ha and AKA 75 years ago if Israel is
after 3,000 years have the right to go
back and demand to be in Palestine then
why not Palestinians who have been
evicted 75 years ago why should we
forget about our own country and let's
go back to the United Nations resolution
that established the state of Israel it
said that there should be two states
Israel and Palestine Israel was created
and Palestine was occupied that is the
reality we all know Mr Mari there's one
thing that we can be sure about about
that that's highly disputed history as
it all is there wasn't a Palestinian
State then there could have
been resolution it's a it's a very sad
thing there wasn't a Palestinian State
created then and that the Palestinians
it will be it will be I assure a lot of
people hope it will be but uh if it
certainly won't be if people are
praising hamz and uh the longer they're
around the less likely it is will ever
be a Palestinian State as far as I can
see but thank you very much Colonel
Richard Kemp in Tel Aviv and thank you
uh to Mustafa bouti our intersection
list tonight in
rala now on uncensored next comedy
Superstars Ricky jaes and Dave Chappelle
have caused massive controversy with
their new Netflix specials well now
surprise surprise there are calls for
them to be cancelled we'll debate
whether comedy has the right to offend
after the break
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak
gun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a f or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million1 140
million pound so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from Jeremy Corbin B Kevin
O Sullivan is the worst presenter on
talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should Hass stay
in power and are there a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that and welcome back to uncensored the
reaction to two controversial comedy
specials over the Christmas holidays has
shown that the culture wars are going
nowhere in
2024 the latest Ricky ja special
Armageddon and David Chappelle's of the
dreamer have topped the Netflix charts
but also caused a furious backlash from
critics here's a clip from both I've
been doing a lot of video messages
recently for terman Leal children you
know the charity Make A Wish Foundation
they're great and they give these dying
kids there like one wish and if it's me
I always say yes and I always start the
video the same way I go why didn't you
wish wish to get
better what you as
well I ain't doing trans jokes no more
you know what I'm going to do tonight
tonight I'm doing your own handicap
jokes well they're not as organized as
the
gays and I love punching
down one critic labeled jav's special
tiresome adolescent offense mongering
while civil rights advocacy group the
national black Justice Coalition called
on Netflix to remove the Chappelle
special from their catalog all together
so should comedy always punch up rather
than down or are comedians free to say
whatever they want even if it offends
joining me now are commentator and
YouTuber Dave rubben comedian James Bar
and here in the studio talk TV
contributor Paula Ron Adrian thank you
all for being with me let me start with
you uh Dave Ruben over in Miami uh do
you think this is a case of sort of
crossing the line or is everything fair
game in
comedy well of course everything's fair
game and it's the job of a good comic to
get as close to that line as you
possibly can say something true and then
through humor uh allow people to laugh
at it and when you poke fun at different
groups what you're doing is showing
everybody that that we're all equal
parts of society uh Chappelle and J are
two of probably the top 10 comics of all
time but you need to only look at a
comedy Legend a guy like Don Rickles who
used to walk up in front of the crowd in
any part of any country and say look at
the black guy the Jew the gay guy the
Italian the WASP the rest of it and what
it did was everybody realized they were
in on the joke that we are a
Multicultural Society and if we can all
poke fun at our silly stereotypes and
everything else then we will actually
figure out ways to build Bridges but
everybody these days seems to want to
burn those bridges down and and make it
seem that our skin color and our
religion is the most important thing
about us uh James over there in Chicago
where do you stand on this these the
these two comedians funny or foul it's
so funny that you accidentally called
him David Chappelle just now but really
he's so obsessed with trans people I
think his name should be deina because
clearly he wants to transition himself I
mean he is absolutely obsessed listen
Dave Chappelle and Ricky Javas are both
incredible comedians they have
historically been brilliant afterlife is
great Dave has used his comedy to punch
up by attacking oppression bringing a
light to racism um joking about why he
doesn't call the police so he knows how
to use comedy to point out oppression
and punch up he's holding people
accountable so why now is he punching
down in my opinion I think Dave
Chappelle has cheapened his act Paula
here in the studio Ricky ja said today
he's playing a character when he's on
stage do you agree with that do you buy
it no I don't and I have to say it is
disappointing because for somebody who
is so intelligent so erudite and knows
the power of language The Power of Words
to have become so basic and simplistic
in his comedy is is disappointing um a
and it is basic and simplistic and if
you're talking about Building Bridges if
you're talking about bringing
communities together how is it that you
are basically poking your
finger at one particular community and
when you talk about um you know making
fun of of sick children of of dying
children just wonder how desperate you
have to be to do that and and you know
we' we we've got a um there's been a a
poll now uh um that's just been uh
commenced I think uh by a mother whose
son sadly had cancer but I I think is
now better and over 13 and a half
thousand people who have signed up to
her poll um to hopefully get that joke
removed from net Netflix and I can
understand why she's doing that um Dave
Rubin you know it raises this question
of whether there are or should be I
don't know about oh God are there any
taboos in comedy I mean I thought I
thought when watching certainly the the
the Ricky jaes one I did think slightly
you know it kind of felt a bit like gosh
choosing really loow hanging fruit to
sort of hit against here you know I mean
but it seems because this is the most
popular show on both these shows most
popular shows on Netflix there's clearly
a huge audience for it uh whether people
find it funny or offensive or not well
look the audience in that room found it
funny and those are the people who were
buying tickets to Ricky J so we could
all Whittle down whether we think that
specific joke you know I don't think he
was making fun of the sick kids per se
he was making sort fun of the absurdity
that someone like him would be on a make
A- wish list that's what the joke really
was about his I don't think and I don't
think anyone on this panel thinks
honestly that Ricky deras has some
grudge against sick kids at all and as
for Chappelle talking about trans people
first off uh you know if if we're going
to do this based on oppression who
you're allowed to talk about based on
perceived oppression are we only allowed
to make jokes about straight white
Christians who are wealthy is that is
that what comedy really is I don't think
so and I don't think anyone else really
thinks so either comedy again is the
great equalizer so if you're just going
to decide okay we can make fun of these
people but not fun of these people
you're going to have an awful lot of
angry people at the end of the day oh
you know I accept that I I would
wholeheartedly accept that because no I
don't believe Ricky Chet thinks that
sick children are a cheap joke and I
don't think actually that Dave Chappelle
and we've seen him on Instagram
attempting to pull back from the
comments that he's made so you know I
fully accept that and that's why I'm
saying first of all it's a cheap shot
and when Dave Chappelle is quoted as
saying that you know uh comedians have
have um it's their duty to be Reckless
this is where I disagree and this is
where we need to look at responsibility
it's not not a comedian's job actually
to be Reckless it's a comedian's job to
be funny and if they're going to do
politics if they're going to do about
marginalized groups then come on be
intelligent about it make us think don't
do cheap School playground Antics James
uh you know all of Comedy James doesn't
it sort of it's all about transgression
to some extent comedians do have a
larger bandwidth than other people in
society to say edgy things uh but do you
think where are the boundaries in your
view listen I think it is a form of
activism and I do agree with both Paula
and Dave here like it is such a nuanced
conversation but really it is at its
best when it's a weapon against the
powerful and riie jav is laughing at
disabled kids it's just it's a waste of
of bandwidth it's a waste of an
opportunity to say something important
and he says he's a free speech activist
but he has a joke about the nword and he
doesn't say the nword so you either are
a free speech activist or you're being a
like which is it well that's very
interesting I I mentioned earlier
producers you know some people use
saying in pieces about the ja special
they're saying the r word and I said
look I mean we've already got the NW and
everyone does know what that means but
if you then got the r word that you're
not meant to say as well we're going to
get a whole alphabet of a word b word CW
that aren't meant to be said Dave Rubin
are there any words you wouldn't
say um well in that you're the guest
host of today's show and maybe you want
to return I'm not going to say them
right now uh but look within context
within context could you are there could
you say the n-word within a certain
context and say it not to be racist of
course you could if you were discusting
discussing historical reasons why people
said it or if you were making fun of
people that use language like that uh
but this this constant push for any time
a comedian if we're all basically I
think we're all agreeing here that these
guys are pretty damn funny so maybe
there's a little lwh hanging fruit here
or there or maybe one joke misses that
is the challenge of a great com that you
are going to spend an awful lot of time
in a bunch of really crappy clubs night
after night perfecting that hour set so
that you can get it on Netflix and it is
possible that one joke may fall flat and
that is the risk that you are going to
have to take Douglas I'll text you some
of those words I just don't want to put
it on television I don't I don't want to
text of those words I don't incriminate
it in your Foul Play Reuben look I mean
what's interesting by the way about this
was that that that Ricky jaes as James
says doesn't say the nword he refers to
the nword but the Chappelle special has
almost nothing but the nword in it I
mean I was sort of a little bit bruised
by just hearing it constantly I I admire
I think Chael is the greatest comic on
the planet but it is a little bit sort
of wearing wow I don't I don't know
about greatest comic on this planet I
accept that he has done amazing things
and made amazing strides in terms of
Comedy um for people of color uh you
being uncomfortable about him using the
nword I'm uncomfortable about lots of
people who use the n-word um there is a
context I agree um it's a poetic context
it's an artistic uh context do I think
that Dave Chappelle is an artist no I
don't um and especially when he says as
I said to be Reckless is his duty that's
disappointing well Paula in the studio
and comedians Dave and James over there
in America thank you all for joining us
tonight I texted you Douglas I texted
you I'm not opening that one I think
Douglas knows the app word no no I'm not
opening that text uh all right up next
on uncensored 2023 was a big year for
the royal family with the coronation but
what does 2024 have in store well one
controversial view is that King Charles
should follow the lead of Denmark's
Queen by announcing a date for his
abdication really already we'll debate
that
next
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police a pro Palestine that is just
not right you swearing off in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solves when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call a teror group is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV welcome back when the queen of
Denmark announced her abdication in her
new year's address it caused shock waves
in Denmark and around the world it's
being called a shrewd move to save the
Danish monarchy and avert disaster after
her son's marriage has been beset by
rumors of an affair in a column for the
guardian Simon Jenkins says King Charles
should follow Denmark's example and tell
us when he will abdicate he argues that
it puts our archaic system to shame and
Simon Jenkins joins me now Sim Jac
thanks so much for joining us so um it
seems a little early in the reign of
King Charles to talk about abdication um
what what's the
point I'm not absolutely sure I said he
should tell us now um that maybe the
headline um getting the better of it but
no I mean I'm rather in favor of um of
constitutional monarchy um but honestly
if you're going to have 7 eight monarchs
around Europe all of whom are hereditary
monarchs none of them got any power but
they are heads of state and if they are
really going all to be in their 80s and
possibly disabled in some sense it makes
monarchy look very odd um and I'm all
I'm saying is I think I think monarchy
unimportant though it is just ort to
grow up and and and and modernize itself
a bit and what I'm I'm suggesting so so
what's your preferred date of uh
departure for the king from the throne
then how long you should give him as in
the case of Denmark he ought to go when
he when he thinks he can't do the job
full fulltime um the queen was obsessed
I know or we know with not showing any
sense that she couldn't do the job um
and she did amazingly well and she
shouldn't be the example for everybody
but in in in four cases as i s in in low
countries in Scandinavia they said look
I think I'm getting on I can't do it as
as intensively as I used to do it um I
think I should hand over to my my
perfectly adequate son or a whoever it
may be and that's where we keep
modernizing the monarchy now hang on
Simon I've got to pick you up on that
you can't give the example of
Scandinavia and the low countries surely
the British Monarchy a different matter
altogether well all right uh we've been
incredibly lucky frankly we've had the
queen for half a century um it is
conceivable we might have had sound and
you've got to be very careful how you
organize this organ the monarchy depends
on popularity it's entirely dependent on
popularity it's not elected not
appointed it's it's inherited you you've
got to ensure that in the case of some
disaster or something going wrong or
whatever or a long illness you can
update it and all I'm suggesting is you
update it in the most obvious way of
anybody doing any job there is it's it's
time expired there comes a point where
you can't be as active as you used to be
you can't do the things you used to have
um and and as they've done in in the
Netherlands in Denmark in Belgium in
Spain they've said all right fine um I
think the time's come to hand over to my
son and I cannot see what's wrong with
that one final question for you Simon
Jenkins I mean isn't it the case that
the sort of age and wisdom of the
Monarch is is a nice sort of
counterbalance to everything else in
society that's obsessed with youth and
glittery new things isn't there
something to be said for a monik who's
seen something seen a lot of the world I
think everything should be said for him
the question is is it indefinite I the
principle that you you you in some sense
have got to go on until you drop dead I
think is simply
absurd Queen Victoria the country was
really sort of under a cloud throughout
her long young at the end of her life um
it's conceivable that the queen might
have gone on for another 10 years and
she her job would had to have been done
by by Prince Charles or somebody else
all I'm really saying is for goodness
sake let's be sensible um the British
Monarchy is wonderful it's spended it's
admired around the world um I think it's
over elaborate it's over pompous it's
too extravagant in all sorts of ways it
doesn't look modern but if it's always
going to be done by someone who's in
their Aces it just looks absurd but all
I'm suggesting is I'm GNA say let's have
a sensible system whereby you do
abdicate and you think you can't do it
particularly well anymore perect there's
nothing wrong with that let's go ahead
with it okay well thank you Sim Jenkins
I've got a couple of guests in the
studio here but thank you and I hope you
keep on working till you drop dead at
any rate uh so thank you agree
in the studio now I have Royal historian
Tessa Dunlop and also the historian
writer and broadcaster Hugo Vickers now
let me first of all ask you both uh what
do you make of that what do you make
Hugo Vickers of Simon jenkins's argument
already we should talk about abdication
well I don't think he understands the
Constitution very well because there are
all sorts of ways that monarchs can um
disappear if they have to um Tommy
lassel who was the Queen's first private
secretary private secret Geor 6 he said
you know the monarchy is a bit like a
rose bush every now and again you have
to chop off a head to keep it going um
so had we ended up let's say with prince
Andrew I'm sure there would have been a
way for him to have been moved to one
side it's actually a very good system
hered the hereditary monarchy means that
you get somebody who is trained from
birth for the job it also means that
they're they're devoted to selfless
service because they know that they
haven't climbed up the greasy pole of
politics they haven't you know fought
their way up and that in some some
degree they shouldn't be there but
having got into that position they then
do a very good job and you saw the
Fantastic transition from the queen to P
Charles which was very couldn't have
been better could it and you saw it
actually even when the queen wasn't you
know totally well in the last year he
stepped in but then when she reappeared
he stepped aside so we got to know him
in this role I think we already knew
didn't we we knew him yes we did quite
familiar with Charles we we had yes we
had had them Prince of Wales around for
a while well on the retirement of the
elderly I think on the basis of this
article written by Simon Jenkins we
should perhaps suggest that he retires
pretty
from the guardian it is a lot of G and I
sit here next to a hardcore believer of
Evangelical monarchist I'm monarchist
light and I think we disagree on many
things but if you've got hereditary
monarchy you can't pick or choose I mean
if we could pick we'd all have picked
Prince William when he had hair to be
king wouldn't he let's be let's be frank
Will May imagine the tinsel and the
glitter and the glamour I'm not so sure
that you should inflict this onto Prince
William any any day that um before it
actually comes to be because as as
Prince Charles now the king will have
discovered he has a lot of extremely
tedious things that he has to do oh the
hardship of secrecy lobbying access to
cabin papers which Palace to lay one's
head at at night I mean it's a tough if
if you think if you think that then you
don't understand one thing about what
he's doing and his work I me he's
incredibly hardworking but the being a
monarch has a lot of responsibility bit
bit like being you know the chairman of
the company not being the sort of you
know the managing director the man who
does the job one other thing I want to
touch on with whil I've got both of you
over Christmas the final episodes of the
crown landed I thought the whole thing
went absolutely bananas towards the end
uh uh but well yeah okay you might say
earlier Seasons but you've got to admit
that this one was especially Bonkers I
thought the dream sequence with the
queen and Tony Blair was I couldn't
believe it made it to screen anyway uh
it sort of seems to me to have put to
rest the whole question of whether or
not the crown is anti monarchy or not
because look at this clip which really
stood out to me from the very end of the
series when we have uh the lake Queen
and Duke of vver standing above what was
to be their final resting place in St
George's Chapel I found this
amazing you were born
ready you are one of a
kind by contrast this
lot the good thing is it's not our
problem this is where we will be you and
I right under this Stone
we'll never hear the screams from inside
there
Philip I found that clip absolutely
amazing Hugo VI I can't think of a
sentiment less likely to come out of the
late dukee of edinburgh's mouth than oh
well when once we're gone it doesn't
matter if the whole thing comes down I
can't imagine the late Queen thinking
anything like that either do you agree I
I'm completely agree with you I think
that if you had any doubt at all about
what Peter Morgan was up to that clip
and the extens of it literally that was
that was what he was trying to get get
across to us I mean clim of the whole
thing yes he was basically saying after
the queen it's all over the part's over
they use that very word oh come on you
too you're looking to be triggered I
thought the last I'm not looking to be
triggered I I think you are I think I
just wanted to watch some good drama and
I didn't see it it was bloated it was
morish but it was hellishly siop fantic
I mean actually with with the exception
of that one moment when Philip says oh
the lock can go and scream away as much
as they want when we're dead everyone W
Harry and
HCK the uh apart from in the first
Seasons the both the other actresses who
played the queen made her out to be this
dur Loveless uh uncaring absolutely cold
these last episodes were santic the only
baddies with The Outsiders Muhammad
alied and poor old Carol Middleton she
was seen as this Iago character social
climbing you know slipping off the PO I
think she come I think she comes out of
it all right Muhammad alide you got to
admit it's kind hard to make into a hero
of the story they did um in the series
before they were rather nice about him
they were actually and they turned they
turned on him which of course they
didn't want to turn on to the RO family
that's why it's true I think Peter's
looking for a Knighthood Peter Morgan I
ridiculous that's so ridiculous I mean
it clearly had from the start a very
strong Republican agenda I was thought
when CLA Foy was doing it that they were
going to say Clare Foy the queen great
all the others ridiculous so after the
queen goodbye and that's exactly what he
says in that last and you've got once
once they went into this sort of weird
terrain where the ghost of Diana appears
and giv gives advice to the queen and
then appears appears on a plane with
Prince Charles I mean they weren't this
drama wasn't exactly sycophantic about
Prince Charles and Diana in fact
actually I thought they made Charles
seem sympathetic and bearing in mind
this was so clearly a drama what it did
was it spread the magic of crazy Mony
with a bit of Hollywood tinsil over the
top right around the globe it actually
means that our all family unlike the
Danish one the one without a king that's
abdicated in Belgium and the other one
in Spain is talked about that young
people know who they are love them or Lo
them I think it's been a positive an
overall win vickas you've written about
all of the factual errors in the early
season of the crown have you done the
later ones as well or is that volume two
long oh yes no I certainly have and they
were published in the times times online
and I shall publish them as an ebook I
made a YouTube um okay well I did that I
did I did an interview as well about
about all the things that went wrong I
mean if you wanted you know historically
wrong the Mrs Thatcher scene when you
know Jeffrey how Lumbers out of bed
makes a speech she looks depressed the
minister say
this come on and then Dennis says the
game's up and then suddenly she says I'm
going to go and see the queen and ask
her to disolve Parliament to save my
skin we know she never did that I just I
felt sorry for the actress playing
Princess Margaret her neck was going to
break I thought it was just going to
snap and I mean they couldn't wait to
Princess Margaret she had a hell of a
time at the end is are we not allowed to
depict old age and the cruelty of it in
the difficulties is that particularly
disgusting actually the way they
portrayed her I really did but then
that's not the only one I mean the way
they had Prince Phillip being blamed for
the death of his sister which I know
that was that was anyway we might not
all agree on this but thank you very
much Tessa and Hugo uncensored next the
police have proudly announced that they
will attend every home burglary after
75% of break-ins went unsolved what's
shocking is that they weren't doing that
already I'm joined by the pack to
discuss that
[Music]
next TV on radio online on your smart
speaker as well criminals to using XL
Bully dogs as weapons to threaten others
no matter how well trained most dog
owners will tell you a dog can turn you
know what I love about to today we do it
all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I'm
don't sort of bear him any ill will
because he delivered the referendum that
he said he would deliver the tor's love
a scrap you can almost see this coming
round the tracks with sella bravman
she's heading up one side and richy soon
at the other the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomim
there not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a fce or
a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so £40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he walks
into a branch of McDonald MC Mouse man
MC mous man MC he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
fil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do I'm going
you're going to Res yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on that
welcome back to uncensored I'm about to
go and join my pack but before I do I'm
going to do a quick fact check uh we had
an interview earlier with uh with uh
Richard Kemp and uh Mustafa barouti and
there was some discussion about whether
Mustafa barouti had ever referred to
Hamas as uh Brave Fighters and we've he
said he had never said that and thought
it had been made up by Colonel Kemp
turns out that in November 2023 uh two
months ago Mr barouti said that the
heroic steadfastness of our people and
their Brave fighters in the Gaza Strip
so sorry about that viewers Mr barouti
seems to have told us of FIB he did in
fact say the words that were said by him
anyway over to the pack today we've got
back thankfully talk TV contributor
Paula Ron Adrian and also the filmmaker
and former Commando James glancy now
we've got quite a lot to get through I
want to start with burglaries uh I was
amazed by this Paula we discovered over
Christmas that that that the police are
actually now going to start going to
houses that are being burgled and
they're going to try to do so in the
first hour because apparently that's
better does this surprise you wow I mean
I was shocked that they've just worked
that out bearing in mind we've been told
because there have been enough reports
that have come out even in October 2023
we recently had a report from um uh one
uh constabulary which said you know the
best way and London Metropolitan Police
as well have been telling us in their
own reports last year best thing to do
about dealing with burglaries is be on
the scene and when you're on the scene
make sure you seal off the scene and
when you've sealed off the scene make
sure you speak to any Witnesses Etc you
know all things that one would expect a
police officer to do in a burglary
Aver we have a Burg depending on theats
you look at
everys yes it's it's over a thousand a
day in this country shocking figures in
terms of burglary and they're just not
taken seriously I am a lone female who
suffered from a burglary and let me tell
you it is horrifying being in a house
when somebody is is is trying to come in
and and who do to do who knows what it's
much more than just losing things it's
it's a whole sense of violation
absolutely and of course it stays with
you as well not just after of course the
event um James I I looked this up
apparently 4% of burglaries this is
going to the home office 4% of
burglaries even result in a charge which
means Lots fewer than that actually get
convicted but what are the police doing
you know in my neighborhood down in West
London I have not seen one Bobby on the
beat and I've lived there five years you
see them driving past at speed so it
doesn't surprise me that they're not
getting to the scenes of crime but I
don't understand why they're not going
back to basics apparently over Christmas
statistics came out that um prosecutions
have been down throughout every police
force except for one in Manchester where
the guy's gone back to basics where the
police chief's gone back to basics what
is the taxpayer paying for yeah the
Manchester stats are really striking
because they've actually realized you
have to as you say go back to basics
with policing and it has effects uh I
was very St over Christmas we also heard
of this there was a woman in uh said
Alban's and she got robbed burgled in
her home and the police didn't show up
and she had CCTV footage of the guy who
burgled her and the police weren't
interested it turns out that in her town
in St Alburn which is about 128,000
people there isn't a police
station yeah I mean that's I was
thinking today uh where is my local
police station right and so that two
questions then came from that why am I
having to think where is my local police
station and then obviously why don't I
know where my local police station is
it's true that I mean that did begin
probably before austerity but you think
back to George Osborne the cuts of fire
stations the armed forces and and your
local police station and and that's it's
got to be rebuilt those capabilities
it's true we all we all used to know
where you could go and report a crime if
it happened now look I want to get to
one other subject with you both and
that's uh the Prime Minister Rishi sunak
is claiming a win on migration figures
uh he's saying that he has the groaning
backlog of 92,000 Legacy assum cases has
finally been cleared I did however check
and it turns out there's still
999,000 cases in back blog um are we
just being kind of fied to on this Paul
by any chance I'm I'm really concerned a
about rak's memory because we saw how
bad it was during his um interview in
the covid inquiry when he was
cross-examined um and now he seems his
grasp of reality seems to be wearing
very thin look first of all he told us
that he was going to reduce the backlog
then he told us oh no no no what I meant
to say was we're going to reduce uced
the Legacy backlog so that was from June
2022 then we were told by um Tim Tom
pbook forgive me if I uh got his first
name wrong um when he was front of the
select committee in the beginning of
December that actually we're going to do
our best to reduce the Legacy backlog to
a number that we can we can attain so
there is just a con this consistent
unreliable information that we're
getting for Richi sunak and is Dominick
cumins going to help him with that well
I want to say I want to read to you
James this quote from the Prime Minister
uh in a New Year's statement Mr sunak
said quote I am determined to end the
burden of illegal migration on the
British people have have we heard that
somewhere before well I mean I I keep
thinking have they employed aliser
Campbell to spin for them to election
because it's just it's so disingenuous
they know they were elected to reduce
immigration legal and illegal and
they've pumped up legal immigration and
they've done nothing about illegal
immigration and so I mean the next
election has definitely fought on this
and they're going to lose a lot of
ground to the Reform Party as a result
of it and you'll you'll probably see in
fact if the if the if labor had labor
would not have got away with the
immigration figures that the
conservators have done no immigration
was Far lower under labor so I think
they've they've got real answers they've
and they've got a real problem going
into the next election haven't they
because uh they they came into office
saying we're going to get migration down
remember we heard David Cameron say he
was going to get it down to the tens of
thousands not the hundreds of thousands
which was was in the 1990s it's not that
long ago and they've got nowhere near
they've got nowhere near and not only
have they got nowhere near but they are
feeding us again this this this this
foolishness quite frankly when actually
what they know is is that our economy
needs immigration we need people here to
work we've got a low birth rate and that
is not going to change generation
there's one there's there there's also
hang on look one in five people in
cities including Liverpool Manchester
uh um less the one in five people of
working age who are capable of working
are not working and are being paid by
the taxpayer to not work surely they can
be made to work before you have to bring
other people in from around the world to
work plus they have extremely low
productivity we've got advancements in
technology it isn't a case of just
import people to replace I know we've
got an aging population but what we're
talking about last year's 1.2 million
people coming in um net migration uh
increasing by 700,000 and the list for
worker visas continues to rise it
continues to expand because we need more
people you know this is a discussion
that I suspect we are going to both
maybe all come back to quite a bit in
the years ahead this is going to be a
long Year by the way for the
conservatives roll on may may somewhere
November November nov whenever it is
that's it for me whatever you're up to
make sure it's uncensored good night
[Music]
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well
they have made a statement condemning
Hamas we expect to see the crown revisit
Harry's anti-semitic Halloween costume
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
done to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear and Al in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard know whether
it's a f or a tragedy talk TV has spoken
exclusively to a member of the Blade
Runners do you have a message for
sadique Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 40
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in 3 years hundreds and hundreds of mice
in a box which he walks into a branch of
McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse man M man
he should be easy enough to catch this
guy shouldn't he I mean he's got house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film